now little earlier I was talking about
retirement with the head of the Peru but
though we no talk of it with my next
guest
in fact after 31 years at Franklin
Templeton including his executive
chairman overseeing 50 billion dollars
worth of funds and at the age of 81 he's
just got a new job but it's still
investing in emerging and frontier
markets I speak of course of the
legendary asset manager dr. martin
mobius whose new firm Mobius Capital
Partners will be launching funds soon so
why are you setting up on your own after
all this time well I see a tremendous
opportunity to focus on ESG
environmental governance social aspects
of investing and because we've been
confronted with that in emerging markets
from the very beginning and now as an
opportunity to break out and do
something new and more intense in that
area it's interesting you know you were
talking about antha Gaston in the
program that was one of our first
investments in emerging markets in 1988
it was a way to get it to Chile and it's
very interesting the way that has
involved a good example of a company
that did a terrific job in governance
they were very open and they expanded
very nicely but it's interesting though
that you're enlightened on environmental
social and governance issues I mean one
doesn't often associate that with
emerging markets talks
exactly if very often you have real
problems in all those issues and that's
the reason why we think there's an
opportunity because there's a growing
awareness in emerging markets about this
and in fact you're seeing governments
moving in the right direction good
example is China the Chinese government
has come out and said look to their
state-owned enterprises
you've got to improve your governance
you've got to have better disclosure and
therefore hopefully increase your
profitability it's amazing in some ways
we're still talking about that given the
very obvious links between poor
investment performance and bad corporate
governance exactly and this is where
we've learned the hard way I mean there
are many cases we've lived through in
all the years we've been in emerging
markets where you know bad corporate
governance resulted in a real disaster
where the disclosure was not there and
we were confronted with real problems
but presumably you're doing this as well
because you've identified already need
among
clients who want to get exposure to
these markets but also want to be seen
to be investing in the right things
exactly so you have a situation now
where there's a growing awareness of the
profitability of emerging markets
emerging market countries are growing at
double the rate of the developed
countries and of course if you look at
the performance particularly recently I
mean just comparing the footsie to
emerging markets index puts you down
emerging markets up by eight and nine
percent since the beginning of the year
so there's a tremendous opportunity to
have good investment returns but we also
realize that if we want to even improve
those returns we've got to do something
about governance and about these are the
issues we mentioned returns I mean
emerging markets last year returns
something like 37 percent I mean feels a
bit low for the market now you're
absolutely right it's something we have
to watch very very carefully and of
course if you look at the u.s. US does
look top you know in terms of valuation
in terms of many many factors the market
is high and of course if the US market
crashes emerging markets will be
affected as well but this effect by the
way is usually quite temporary and of
course we're moving into a right
tightening environment the Federal
Reserve probably gonna raise rates three
times this year historically speaking
that hasn't been great for emerging
markets either well you know any
interesting we did some studies on that
we found that yes in some cases higher
Fed rates was bad for emerging markets
but there have been other cases where
higher federates
resulted in a higher performance for
emerging markets so there's no clear
predictable distinction correlation with
these factors so hopefully you know this
rate rise will be very gradual which is
way it looks at this stage of the game
and interesting enough the US dollar are
getting weaker and emerging market
countries getting stronger also helps
emerging markets performance in dollar
terms I mentioned China has been one
market where governance is being
strengthened where are the other markets
that you like the look of right
India India of course is a huge market
potential growth as well India is
actually growing faster than China now
and the Indian market is now getting
much more mature much more liquid and a
lot of things are happening on the
governance arena that is quite good Mike
wells from Peru was telling me earlier
today million people are going to enter
of working age again I went to the
workforce every month in age rate the
next few years I mean show you the
stunning opportunities are available
it's quite incredible
it's a grueling job though yours going
you know visiting these markets wearing
out shoe leather why are you still doing
it at 81 well I love it I love travel I
love meeting new people being in new
places in fact I just returned from
Chile from Santiago Chile and again it
was a great experience for me because I
see the changes that have taken place
over these years I mean when we first
invested in active aster I was with the
chairman mr. Lukic in the town of
Antofagasta and it was a derelict town
there was a brewery behind us we were
walking in the city and it was a brewery
we noticed behind us that was as well
derelict and he said I'm gonna buy that
brewery and make it a success and that's
exactly what he did one of the richest
countries in the world of course exactly
gonna leave it there I'm afraid maybe
it's great pleasure to have you on the
show hope you come back again thank you
Anna